Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest Is History. Now, once again, we are in London. Tom Holland has wrote me into one of his exciting walking tours of our nation's capital. But this time, it's a tour with a bit of a difference, because, Tom, we're doing Hidden London, the secrets of London. Very exciting.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目，并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入会员俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。你好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。现在，我们又一次来到了伦敦。汤姆·霍兰（Tom Holland）拉着我参加了他精心策划的、关于我们国家首都的精彩徒步之旅。但这一次，这是一次有些与众不同的旅行，因为汤姆，我们要探索“隐秘的伦敦”，即伦敦的秘密。非常令人兴奋。
Well, what I thought was, I mean, one of the things about London, it's an unbelievably historic city, but there are lots of places where the history is kind of hidden. Yeah. But nevertheless, when you know what went on, when you have a sense of the kind of the ghosts that haunt it. I mean, one of the problems with London is that although it's an incredibly historic city, there are many of the most historic corners of it where the history isn't really visible. Yeah. So you have a track record, the Christmas Carol podcast, the Roman London podcast, of dragging me to what appear to be very banal corners of the city, outside branches of coffee shops and loss adjusters offices and things like that and to be frank that's where we are again we're at a big junction the old bailey now the old bailey is
嗯，我的想法是，伦敦的特点之一在于，它是一座历史极其悠久的城市，但其中有很多地方，历史都被某种程度上隐藏了起来。是的。然而，当你了解了曾经发生过的事情，当你对那些萦绕其间的幽灵有所感知时……我的意思是，伦敦的一个问题在于，尽管它是一座历史悠久的城市，但在许多最具历史厚重感的角落，历史并不是那么显而易见。是的。所以你有着丰富的记录，比如圣诞颂歌播客、罗马伦敦播客，你总是拉着我去城市里那些看似非常平庸的角落，比如咖啡店分店和理赔员办公室之类的地方，坦白说，我们现在又来到了这样一个地方：一个大路口，老贝利（Old Bailey），现在老贝利是
very historic yes the old the old bailey which is the great courthouse is nearby there's a church i know you love a church so i imagine that's a play but the exciting thing for me is that i don't know where we're going exactly it's a mystery tour tour. So over the course of the lockdown, you know, you could only go out and have exercise if you went from door and out and then back to your door. Yeah. So we just ended up doing loads and loads of walks and I increasingly themed them
历史非常悠久，是的，老贝利，也就是那座宏伟的法院就在附近，还有一座教堂，我知道你很喜欢教堂，所以我想那是一个景点，但对我和最兴奋的是，我并不确切知道我们要去哪里，这是一次神秘之旅。所以在封城期间，你知道的，你只能出门锻炼，从家门出去然后再走回门。是的。所以我们最后做了大量大量的步行，我越来越多地把它们作为主题
kind of around aspects of London history. So we did Roman London, we did Medieval London, we did Tudor London, We did the ghosts of London. We did Dickens's London, all kinds of different themes. And I've brought you to the area of the city that had the most intersections. So if you imagine them as ley lines, this was the kind of the spaghetti junction of London, psycho geographical walks. And as you say, Dominic, it doesn't look... It's not particularly picturesque.
围绕伦敦历史的各个方面展开。所以我们做了罗马伦敦、中世纪伦敦、都铎伦敦、伦敦幽灵、狄更斯的伦敦，各种不同的主题。我把你带到了这座城市交汇点最多的地区。所以如果你把它们想象成地脉（ley lines），这里就是伦敦的“意大利面条式”立交桥，也就是心理地理学徒步之旅。正如你所说，多米尼克，它看起来并不……它并不是特别风景秀丽。
It's very, very unappealing. But, so we did a walk of Roman London. We did. And talked about the wall. We are on the site of one of the gates in the Roman wall. And this was Newgate. And according to our old friend John Stowe, the Elizabethan antiquarian,
非常非常没有吸引力。但是，我们做过一次罗马伦敦的徒步。我们确实做过。并且谈到了城墙。我们现在正处于罗马城墙某座城门的遗址上。这就是纽gate（Newgate）。根据我们老朋友约翰·斯托（John Stowe）的说法，这位伊丽莎白时代的古董学者，
it was called Newgate because it was built in the reign of either henry the first or stephen so in the norman period was in fact the new gate he was wrong um he was wrong because it is in fact a roman gate and from here the road went it's watling street that goes up to um to basically to to the cotswolds to your to your neck of the world so if you just keep yeah you just keep heading along hoban viaduct you get back home so that's what so tom for those people who don't know london we are still within the walls of that well just by the walls of the city yes so so the so the roman wall marks the line of the city of london pretty much um so we are just on the edge of the city. And I think one of the reasons why this area of London is that we're going to go and look.
它之所以叫纽盖特（Newgate，意为新门），是因为它是在亨利一世或斯蒂芬统治时期建造的，所以在诺曼时期，它其实是一座新门。他猜错了，嗯，他猜错了，因为它实际上是一座罗马城门。从这里出去的道路是沃特林街（Watling Street），一直通往嗯，基本上通往科茨沃尔德（Cotswolds），也就是你老家那个方向。所以如果你一直，是的，你只要沿着霍本高架桥（Holborn Viaduct）一直走，就能回到家了。所以，汤姆，对于那些不了解伦敦的人来说，我们仍然在那个——或者说就在城市城墙的边上，对吧？所以，罗马城墙大致标记了伦敦城的边界，嗯，所以我们正好在城市边缘。我想，伦敦这一带之所以吸引我们前来参观，原因之一在于——
So we're going to go north away from the line of the Roman wall is that the stuff that went on just outside the city wall is incredibly interesting. So that's part of what we're going to look at. But but just a bit on Newgate. Newgate, of of course is famous as the prison of course so um there was there was a kind of prison here from from the end of the 12th century right the way up to 1902 1902 surprises me yeah so long because it's sort of very Dickensian image isn't it absolutely yes yes and so um vast kind of criminal complex and the fact that the the old bailey is there you've got the golden statue of justice with her blindfolded with the sword and the scales of justice, is a reminder of the fact that this was the site where people were arrested, chucked into prison.
我们要向北走，离开罗马城墙的路线，因为城墙外紧邻的区域所发生的事情极其有趣。这就是我们要探讨的内容的一部分。不过，关于纽盖特，我们还是要多说一点。纽盖特，当然作为监狱而闻名，所以，嗯，这里从12世纪末一直到1902年，一直都存在某种监狱。1902年，这让我挺意外的。是的，时间跨度这么长，因为它给人一种非常狄更斯式的印象，不是吗？绝对是的，是的。因此，嗯，这里曾是一个庞大的犯罪综合体，而老贝利就在那里，正义女神的金色雕像戴着眼罩，手持长剑和天平，这都在提醒人们，这里曾是人们被捕、被扔进监狱的地方。
And in fact, opposite us, where we're standing now, there is a pub called the Viaductaduct tavern yes i was just eyeing up that bub and in the basement where they store the beer you're a great man for a london basement tom i know yes well there are no roman ruins here sadly um but there are there are um surviving cells in which debtors were kept and wow so they're down down in the basement so if you're ever having a drink in the Viaduct Oven, you can ask the landlord, go and have a look. And there is apparently still a condemned man's cell on the far side. You'd be kept in that slightly larger because...
事实上，在我们对面，也就是我们现在站立的地方，有一家叫做“高架桥酒馆”（Viaduct Tavern）的酒吧。是的，我刚才正打量那家酒吧呢。在他们储存啤酒的地下室里，你真是一个热爱伦敦地下室的人，汤姆。我知道，是的，这里虽然没有罗马遗迹，真遗憾，但却保存有当年关押债务人的牢房。哇！它们就在地下室里。所以如果你哪天在“高架桥酒馆”喝酒，你可以问问房东，去参观一下。据说，在最里面还有一个死囚牢房。那个会稍微大一点，因为……
Of the Old Bailey. Yeah, of the Old Bailey. So you get loads of visitors. People who want to see someone who's about to be hanged. Yes, of course. And then you'd be led along a tapering corridor, so it would get narrower and narrower and narrower as you got to the gallows. In case you kind of, you know, as the prisoner, you'd have a panic and try and run away.
因为靠近老贝利。对，因为老贝利。所以你会接待大量的访客。那些想看一眼即将被绞死的人的人。是的，当然。然后你会沿着一条逐渐变窄的走廊被带过去，随着你越来越接近绞刑架，走廊会变得越来越窄、越来越窄、越来越窄。以防作为囚犯的你突然感到恐慌，试图逃跑。
So they would execute people on site? Well, so the main execution site for a lot of the period was Tyburn Hill, which is now Marble Arch. And Hoban Viaduct you keep going on it ends up becoming Oxford Street so you'd be put on a tumbril and you'd be taken all this kind of about three miles uh and people would line and cheer and it'll be a great holiday great fun um that changed in 1783 right and we're next to a church, and basically this space here, so there's a kind of, the church is called, brilliantly, St Sepulchre without Newgate, so outside Newgate,
所以他们会在现场对人们执行死刑？嗯，在很长一段时间里，主要的刑场其实是泰本山（Tyburn Hill），也就是现在的大理石拱门（Marble Arch）。顺着霍本高架桥一直走，最后就会变成牛津街（Oxford Street）。所以你会坐上运囚车，被押送大约三英里左右的距离，人们会在街道两旁列队欢呼，这会是一个盛大的节日，非常有趣。这种情况在1783年发生了改变。而且我们现在挨着一座教堂，基本上，这片空地……这座教堂的名字非常棒，叫“纽盖特外圣塞普尔克雷”（St Sepulchre without Newgate），也就是在纽盖特外面，
so we're outside the city walls here. This is where the gallows were, and it was a huge spectacle. So Dickens came here to see it, Thackeray came to see an execution. Dickens' descriptions of going to see executions. Dickens had a real fascination for executions, didn't he? He saw one in Rome, didn't he? Yeah, he did. It was special to see him. But a kind of legacy of that is that inside the church,
所以我们当时就在城墙外面。这里就是绞刑架的所在地，而且曾是一个巨大的奇观。狄更斯曾来到这里观看，萨克雷（Thackeray）也曾来看过行刑。狄更斯对观看行刑的描述……狄更斯对行刑有着真正着迷的情结，对吧？他在罗马看过一次，不是吗？是的，他确实看过。亲眼目睹这种事对他来说很特别。但其中一个遗留至今的传统是，在教堂内部，
inside St Sepulchre without Newgate, there is an executioner's bell, which was endowed by a pious merchant in 1604. So it would sound whenever an execution was due to be held. To summon the locals? Yes, to summon the locals. And these verses would be chanted. Prepare you, for tomorrow you will die. Watch all and pray. The hour is drawing near. Prepare you for tomorrow you will die. Watch all and pray.
在纽盖特外圣塞普尔克雷教堂里，有一口行刑钟，这是由一位虔诚的商人于1604年捐赠的。每当有行刑即将举行时，它就会敲响。是为了召唤当地人吗？是的，召唤当地人。并且会吟诵这样的诗句：“做好准备吧，明天你将死去。时刻警醒，虔诚祈祷。时刻临近。做好准备吧，明天你将死去。时刻警醒，虔诚祈祷。”
The hour is drawing near. That you before the Almighty must appear. Examine well yourselves in times repent. That you may not to the eternal flames be sent. Well, I'd like to hear that before I make excuses. Exactly. So I think that's all kind of very invigorating and inspiring. And the other invigorating, inspiring aspect of this corner
“时刻临近。你必须在全能上帝面前显现。仔细省察自身，及时忏悔。免得你被投入永恒的烈火之中。”好吧，在我想借口开溜之前，我可不想听到这个。完全赞同。所以我觉得这些都非常令人振奋和鼓舞。而这个街区的另一个令人振奋、鼓舞人心的方面，
is that here we have London's oldest water fountain, drinking fountain. So this is a, it says the first metropolitan public drinking fountain erected on Hoban Hill in 18, what is that, 39? And removed when the viaduct was constructed in 1867. So there are two cups here still. Two cups, but no water, sadly. No. So this is sort of classic Victorian public service engineering, isn't it?
就在于这里有伦敦最古老的喷泉，也就是饮水喷泉。所以这是一个……上面写着“第一座大都会公共饮水喷泉，于18……那是多少年？39年？在霍本山（Hoban Hill）竖立，并在1867年高架桥修建时被移除。”所以这里现在仍然有两个杯子。有两个杯子，但遗憾的是没有水。没有。所以这是一种典型的维多利亚时期的公共服务工程，对吧？
Yes. And it's the conjunction of gallows and temperance movement that is very, very Victorian. Yeah, so some people presumably will be coming here to watch the execution and getting absolutely tanked up. Yeah. And they're putting water here to, you know, calm down. To try and regulate it.
是的。绞刑架与禁酒运动的结合，非常非常具有维多利亚时期的特色。是的，所以可以推测，有些人会来这里观看行刑，然后喝得酩酊大醉。对。他们在这里放置水是为了，你知道的，让人冷静下来。试图进行规范和管理。
Yeah. So that's Newgate. So it's a kind of, you know, you could walk along here and have no sense of it. But I think once you feel it, maybe I'm being over romantic. I think, you know, the sense of misery and oppression does slightly ooze up out of the out of the tarmac maybe i'm right in thinking tom that this is where some tudor in the tudor period some monks uh were brought here because they'd refused to swear the oath of allegiance to henry the eighth that's right so so we're going to head north now along Gilt Spur Street. Yeah. And Gilt Spur Street, as its name suggests, this is where they would manufacture spurs, gild them.
对。这就是纽盖特。所以这是一种……你知道的，你走过这里，可能完全感觉不到这些。但我觉得一旦你有了这种感知——也许是我太浪漫主义了——我觉得那种苦难和压抑感确实会微微从柏油路面下渗出来。也许我的看法没错，汤姆，这就是某些都铎时期——在都铎时期，一些修士被带到这里，因为他们拒绝向亨利八世宣誓效忠？没错，所以我们现在要沿着金斯帕街（Giltspur Street）向北走。是的。正如其名，金斯帕街（Giltspur Street）过去是人们制造马刺并为其镀金的地方。
And we're going to head up towards Smithfield, which was a huge open space outside the city of London to which cattle would be brought from across the country. And to this day, Smithfield is still the major meat market. It's the only one that continues from the Middle Ages on the same place. But it was also, in medieval times, the site of the great Priory of St Bartholomew. And we'll talk a bit more about that when we get to it. But yes, so when the Priory of St Bartholomew was closed down, there were about 10 monks that refused to take the Oath of Allegiance to Henry VIII, and so they were brought to New Gutgell and left to starve.
我们要朝史密斯菲尔德（Smithfield）方向走去。史密斯菲尔德是伦敦城外的一片巨大开阔地，全国各地的牛都被赶到这里。直到今天，史密斯菲尔德依然是主要的肉类市场。它是唯一一个从中世纪延续至今、且仍在原址运营的市场。但在中世纪，这里也是宏伟的圣巴托罗缪修道院（Priory of St Bartholomew）的所在地。等我们到了那里，我们会再多聊聊这个。不过是的，当圣巴托罗缪修道院被解散时，大约有10名修士拒绝向亨利八世宣誓效忠，于是他们被带到纽盖特，任其饿死。
And as we will see, there are quite a lot of memorials reaching back to the Tudor period, back even to the Middle Ages. And one of the reasons why it's so rich in early modern and medieval monuments is because of course back in the city in 1666 you had the great fire which incinerated vast you know huge amounts of the medieval city but dominic if you look here as we come down giltspur street you'll see up ahead there is uh cock lane a golden no up up there oh yeah it's a golden statue of a fat boy this boy is in memory put up for the late fire of london occasioned by the sin of gluttony 1666 you're trying to tell me something tom so so this this this golden boy marks the furthest limit that the great fire reached
正如我们将看到的，这里有相当多的纪念碑，追溯到都铎时期，甚至可以追溯到中世纪。这里之所以拥有如此丰富的早期现代和中世纪古迹，原因之一当然是，1666年当你在城里遭遇伦敦大火时，大火焚毁了大量的中世纪城市建筑。但是多米尼克，如果你看这里，当我们沿着金斯帕街走下来时，你会看到前面有一条……哦，科克巷（Cock Lane），有一个金色的……不，前面，哦，是的，那是一个胖男孩的金色雕像。这个男孩是为了纪念1666年因暴食之罪而引发的伦敦大火而竖立的。你是在试图告诉我什么吗，汤姆？所以，这个金色的男孩标志着大火蔓延的最远边界。
so it swept through newgate up giltsburg street and it was stopped here and the sin of gluttony is this a reference to sort of pudding lane baker's shops the boy at pie corner was erected to commemorate the staying of the great fire which beginning at pudding lane was ascribed to the sin of gluttony when not attributed to the papists as on the monument and the boy was made prodigiously fat to enforce the moral the thing is that by today's standards he's not really that fat he looks quite healthy he was originally built into the front of a public house called the fortune of war which used to occupy this site and was pulled down in 1910 now here's an interesting thing Tom the fortune of war was the chief house of call
所以它从纽盖特席卷而过，沿着金斯帕街一路烧过来，最终在这里被阻止了。暴食之罪？这难道是指布丁巷（Pudding Lane）的面包店吗？“馅饼角（Pie Corner）的男孩”是为了纪念大火的扑灭而竖立的，大火始于布丁巷，当时被归咎于暴食之罪，而不是像纪念碑上那样归咎于天主教徒。而且这个男孩被做得很胖，以此来强化这个道德寓意。问题是，按今天的标准来看，他其实并没有那么胖，他看起来相当健康。他最初是被镶嵌在一家名为“战争命运”（Fortune of War）的酒馆正面的，这家酒馆以前就占据着这个地方，但在1910年被拆除了。好了，这里有个有趣的事实，汤姆，“战争命运”是河以北复活者（resurrectionists）的主要落脚点。
north of the river for resurrectionists. So body snatchers, yeah. In body snatching days years ago, very strangely punctuated this, in body snatching days years ago, the landlord used to show the room where on benches around the walls the bodies were placed,
也就是盗尸贼，是的。在当年盗尸盛行的年代——这里的话题转折得非常奇怪——在当年盗尸盛行的年代，房东过去常常带人参观这样一个房间：房间墙壁周围的长椅上曾摆放着尸体，
labelled with the snatchers' names, waiting till the surgeons at St Bartholomew's could run round and appraise them. Right, because the Priory is also a hospital. Right. So St Bartholomew's Hospital is another... Yes, we were opposite St Bartholomew's Hospital, one of London's most famous hospitals,
上面贴着盗尸贼的名字，一直等到圣巴托罗缪医院（St Bartholomew's）的外科医生们跑过来对它们进行评估。对，因为修道院也是一家医院。没错。所以圣巴托罗缪医院是另一个……是的，我们就在圣巴托罗缪医院的对面，这是伦敦最著名的医院之一，
probably the most famous. Yeah, so I think this is an absolutely brilliant... This sense that... I mean, it's, again, a very anonymous corner apart from the statue of the fat boy. You'd have no sense that this is where body snatchers were hanging out. No, no, not at all. And yet this is absolutely why this is such an incredibly interesting
可能也是最著名的一家。是的，所以我觉得这是一个绝对精彩的……这种感觉——我的意思是，除了那个胖男孩的雕像之外，这里再次成了一个非常默默无闻的角落。你绝对不会意识到这里曾是盗尸贼流连忘返的地方。不，不，完全不会。然而这正是为什么伦敦的这个部分如此极其有趣、非常值得漫步探索的原因，因为它到处都是这样的幽灵。说到幽灵，我们正身处一条对任何了解幽灵传说的人来说都非常非常著名的街道拐角处，这也是我们在关于幽灵的精彩节目中探讨过的主题。这就是科克巷。好，现在我们来聊聊科克巷。所以科克巷，很明显，这个名字暗示了这里曾经的屠夫产品。是的，所以这里过去仍然有道路、小巷之类的。所以它曾经是一个
part of London to walk around, because it's absolutely full of these kind of ghosts. And talking of ghosts, we are on the corner of a road that is very, very famous to anyone who knows about ghosts and which featured in the wonderful episode we did on ghosts. And that is Cock Lane. Right. Now let's talk about Cock Lane. So Cock Lane, obviously, that's an allusion to the butcher's produce that is here. Right. So there are still roads, lanes, whatever. So it's kind of a
家禽商巷，这是一个家禽商巷。嗯，但是，在那条街上……科克巷曾是……那是一栋房子，在18世纪，1762年，这可能是整个伦敦历史上最臭名昭著闹鬼事件的发生地。这是一个喧闹鬼（poltergeist），它自称是一个被前房客谋杀的女子的幽灵。这成为了伦敦最大声谈论的话题。每个人都在议论纷纷。人们纷纷涌来一探究竟。我们当时请到了罗吉尔·克拉克（Roger Clarke），对吧？
poulterers lane it's a poulterers lane um so but but down there so cock lane was um it was a house that in the 18th century um 1762 it's probably the most notorious haunting in the whole of london's history um and it's a poltergeist which claimed to be the ghost of a woman who'd been murdered by a former lodger. And it became the biggest talking point in London. Everyone was talking about it. And people came in and started kind of finding out. We had Roger Clarke, didn't we?
我们请罗吉尔·克拉克给我们讲述了所有这些。所以如果你对完整的故事感兴趣，可以回去听听那一期。约翰逊博士（Dr. Johnson）曾去调查过。是的，他确实去了。他可不是个出色的捉鬼猎人。我想我们当时谈到过……约翰逊博士，捉鬼猎人。是的。有一个很棒的电视剧，我觉得这应该会……我觉得我们当时聊过，什么才是一棒的电视剧，顺便说一句，我觉得这个创意是我先想到的。但是，对于灵异现象的粉丝来说很遗憾的是，人们最终认定这一切其实都是一场骗局。
We had Roger Clarke telling us all about that. So if you're interested in the full story of that, go back and listen to that. Dr. Johnson went and investigated it. He did, yeah. Not a great ghost hunter. I think we talked then about... Dr. Johnson, ghost hunter. Yeah. There's a great TV series on think it'd be i mean i think we talked about yeah what is a great tv series and by the way i thought of it first um but um sadly for fans of the psychic it it basically people decided it had all been a fraud
是的，而且说实话，就街道而言，它现在是一条相当单调乏味、毫不起眼的街道，不是吗？但这就是伦敦这个角落有趣的地方，汤姆，伦敦很少有哪个地方能像这里这样——它现在是一条相当单调乏味、毫不起眼的街道，不是吗？它带着一丝维多利亚时期的气息。关于伦敦的这个角落，汤姆，伦敦很少有哪个地方能像这里这样，在浪漫的幽灵传说记忆与坦白说有些平庸的现实之间，存在着如此巨大的鸿沟。是的，我觉得这正是让伦敦的历史如此难以捉摸的原因所在。是的。这不像是在参观罗马甚至巴黎，它不是那种直白地展现在你面前的东西。是的。话虽如此，不过幸运的是，由于我们现在已经走出了大火的边界，这里依然有一些令人难以置信的、
yeah and actually as streets go it's a pretty drab and unprepossessing looking street now isn't it but that's the funny thing about this corner of london tom there can be very few places in london It's a pretty drab and unprepossessing looking street now, isn't it? It's got a faint hint of the Victoria. About this corner of London, Tom, there can be very few places in London where there's such a sort of gulf between the romantic kind of ghost-haunted memory and the frankly slightly banal reality. Yeah, and I think that that is exactly what makes London's history so hard to get a grasp on. Yeah. It's not like going around rome or even paris um it's it's not kind of in your face yeah but having said that because fortunately we're now going beyond the limits of the great fire there are some incredible
见证伦敦过去的古迹。我很期待。所以我想我们应该继续向前走，去寻找圣巴托罗缪修道院。圣巴托罗缪修道院是由一个叫拉希尔（Rahere）的人建立的，拉希尔是亨利一世宫廷中的一位显赫朝臣。亨利一世是征服者威廉的小儿子，继承了威廉二世（即红脸威廉）的王位。有些传说甚至说拉希尔曾是亨利一世的小丑。哦，真不错。如果他真的是个小丑，那就太美妙了。他去罗马朝圣时生病了，于是他祈祷，圣巴托罗缪的异象显现在他面前。
monuments to london's past i look forward to so i think we should we should head up now towards um saint bartholomew's priory um and saint bartholomew's priory was founded by a man called rahir and rahir was um a leading courtier at the court of henry the first so um the youngest son of william the conqueror um succeeded william william the second william Rufus. And some stories say that Rahir was Henry I's jester. Oh, nice. It would be wonderful to think that he was. He went to Rome on pilgrimage, got sick, prayed, and a vision of St Bartholomew came to him.
他的病好了，得以痊愈，于是他许下誓言，发誓回来后要建立一座修道院和一家医院。他回来后，亨利一世给了他一块靠近史密斯菲尔德的土地，就在城外……所以在城外。在城外。而且一次又一次，当你审视罗马城墙的走向，
He got healed, got cured, and he made a vow that he would come back and he would found a priory in a hospital. And he came back, and Henry I gave him land by Smithfields, so just outside... So outside the city. Outside the city. And again and again, when you look at the line of the Roman walls
再看看那些修道院、男女修道院、修道院分院等建筑所处的位置时，它们都紧邻城墙，原因显而易见：罗马城墙提供了大量的建筑材料，供他们拿来使用。因此，当宗教改革到来时，大部分修道院都被变卖了，不过并非全部，正如我们稍后将看到的。修士们曾一直管理着医院，所以伦敦市民非常担心，如果修士们运营的医院被关闭，他们将失去那些医疗服务。
and you look at where monasteries, priories, abbeys, so on, are situated, they're next to the walls for the obvious reason that the Roman walls provided a vast quantity of building material that they could then put into it. So when the Reformation came, most of the priory got sold off, although not all of it, as we will see in due course. And the monks had run the hospital. so people in london were kind of very worried that uh they'd be left without the medical services that the monks had been
因此，他们向亨利一世请愿，要求基本上重建这家医院，于是情况确实如此，除非你是那些被他推搡着活活饿死的修士之一。是的，嗯，那显然就没那么好了。现在真可惜，因为我们正站在圣巴托罗缪医院的正门前。是的，而且这里到处都是脚手架。所以完全契合这里的氛围，真的，是的，这真是一个极好的隐喻，我得发挥我那惊人的想象力去查阅博德利图书馆（Bodleian）了。或者查阅博德利图书馆。但在那些脚手架后面，隐藏着伦敦唯一一尊亨利一世的雕像。非常贴心的是，他们在脚手架上贴了一张它的照片。
providing at the hospital and so they petitioned henry the eighth to basically refound it and so that's exactly what happened unless you're one of those monks who he shoved into starve to death yeah well that's obviously that's less good now it's a shame because we're standing in front of the main entrance into saint bartholomew's hospital yeah and uh it's absolutely covered in scaffolding so keeping with the spirit of this exactly exactly it's kind of yes a wonderful metaphor i shall have to use my uh my prodigious imagination consult the Bodleian. Or consult the Bodleian. But behind that scaffolding is the only statue of Henry VIII that stands in London. And very kindly, they have put a picture of it on the scaffolding.
所以我们刚才看到了那个金色的胖男孩。好吧，另一个胖男孩：胖亨利一世。是的。所以这是处于鼎盛时期的亨利一世，对吧？这不是风流倜傥的哈里王子的亨利一世。这是约翰·维加斯（Johnny Vegas，英国喜剧演员）形象的亨利一世。是的，这是灌肠疗法的阶段。
So we've got the fat golden boy down there. Well, another fat boy. Fat Henry VIII. Yeah. So this is Henry VIII in his pomp, isn, another fat boy. Fat Henry VIII. Yeah. So this is Henry VIII in his pomp, isn't it? It's not Henry VIII as Prince Harry. It's Henry VIII as Johnny Vegas. Yes, this is the enema.
也就是腿部溃疡的阶段。所以圣巴托罗缪医院，至今仍是一家正常运营的医院。是的。大概在10到15年前，曾有人讨论过要关闭它，但它依然在运作。当然，这里非常著名，因为威廉·哈维（William Harvey）正是在这里研究出了血液循环，不，是输血……哦，血液循环。不仅如此，这里还因为一个非常著名的虚构情侣的初次相遇而闻名，当然就是华生——华生当然是从阿富汗战场回来了，是的，他受了伤，
Yeah, the enema stage. The ulcer on the leg stage. So St. Bartholomew's Hospital, still a functioning hospital. Yeah. There were people, there were talk of closing it down i think about 10 15 years ago but it's it it carries on um and of course very famous um this is where harvey william harvey developed the blood transfusion blood transfusion but also very very famous for um the first meeting of the celebrated fictional couple of course watson of course has got back from afghanistan yeah he is
没错。然后福尔摩斯正在化学实验室里，一位朋友对华生说，你知道的，我在医院里认识一个人，他有点古怪，但他正在找人合租公寓。是的，他们就在这里相遇了。而且我觉得在那个……在那个版本里，呃，更新的版本里，是的，福尔摩斯是从圣巴托罗缪医院跳下去的，而不是莱辛巴赫瀑布（Reichenbach Falls），以此作为一种致敬。一个伏笔，是的。是的，作为一种致敬。所以，我认为任何对伦敦历史感兴趣的人都会为这家医院能够继续运营、并继续沿用圣巴托罗缪这个名字而感到高兴。现在我们要去修道院了，我们现在——你知道的，我们在一条街上，我们在医院外面。在中世纪，修道院的范围一直延伸到我们现在步行的地方。我们正走在开阔的街道上，正接近一座都铎时期的门楼，是的，上面带有都铎时期建筑的精髓，也就是黑色的木梁和白色的粉刷。是的，但门楼下方有一个拱门，实际上是13世纪的建筑。所以都铎时期的门楼显然是在都铎时期增建的。哦，这就是历史播客的魅力！后来它被遮挡住了，我想它是在二战大轰炸（Blitz）之后被重新发现的。
wounded yep and and uh holmes is in the chemical laboratory and a friend of course says you know gonna know a guy at the hospital who is a little bit eccentric but uh he's looking for someone to share rooms yeah and and they meet here and i think in the um in the uh the bend it come about update yes this is where he fall this, rather than the Reichenbach Falls, he jumps off St Bartholomew's Hospital as a kind of a tribute. A nod, yes. Yes, as a nod to that. So, I mean, I think anyone with an interest in London's history
所以他们拆除了外立面，发现了这个神奇的东西。是的，这太壮观了，因为那个时期的建筑在伦敦实在是凤毛麟角，对吧？对，确实如此。不过我们现在要前往修道院仅存的部分。当我们穿过门楼，沿着一条小路走进去时——这里曾经是修道院的中殿（nave），也就是教堂的主体部分。是的。按照传统的风格，在原本应该是教堂正中心的地方，竟然突兀地矗立着一座非常平庸的办公大楼。
is glad that the hospital carries on and continues to bear the name of of saint bartholomew now the priory which we're now you know we're on a street we're outside the hospital in medieval times the priory is ran where we are walking now we're on the open street so we're approaching a tudor gatehouse yeah um which is and you can see there's kind of um the essence of tudor architecture so black beams white paint yes um but there's an archway beneath it which is actually 13th century so the tudor gatehouse was added obviously in the tudor period oh that's history podcasting and it then got it then got covered over and i think it got kind of rediscovered after the blitz
是的，教堂，是的。但我们现在正在接近现在的大圣巴托罗缪堂（St Bartholomew the Great）教区教堂，这里保存了原始修道院的一部分，这是伦敦现存最古老的教区教堂。这是一座非常漂亮的小教堂，非常非常的漂亮。它的历史可以追溯到诺曼时期，所以它有一座砖砌塔楼，红砖塔楼。所以砖塔是后来加建的。但主建筑部分，当我们走进去——你以前来过这里吗？从未。好吧，所以任何看过《四个婚礼和一个葬礼》（Four Weddings and and a Funeral）的人都会认出，这里就是片中最后那场婚礼的拍摄地。也就是休·格兰特（Hugh Grant）甩掉“鸭脸”新娘、独自离开的地方。哦，是的。这绝对是展现你模仿休·格兰特口音的绝佳机会：“哦，外面在下雨吗？哦，真是太感人了……”因此，当你走进教堂内部，
so um they they removed the facing and discovered this kind of amazing yeah it's magnificent uh because there's very very few buildings of that period yeah in london right yeah i mean right uh but we're now going to the surviving chunk of the priory so when the prior so we're now walking through the gateway and we're walking down a pathway. And this was the nave of the Priory. So this was the kind of the main body of the church. Yeah. In traditional fashion, there's an incredibly banal office block right in the middle of what would have been the center of the church.
是的，你会瞬间回到中世纪。一进门，在你的右手边，你就会看到一段回廊（cloisters），仅仅是回廊四个边中的其中一边。
Yes. church yes but we're now approaching uh what what is now the parish church of saint bartholomew the great yeah which preserves um a section of uh of the original priory um and it is the oldest surviving parish church in london it's a very handsome little church very very handsome church it reaches back to uh to the norman period so it's got a brick tower, red brick tower. So the brick tower is later. Yeah. But the main body, when we, have you been here before? Never. Okay, so anyone who's seen Four Weddings
但走进去后，你会瞬间置身于这个非凡的空间中。这里是交汇点，当你走进来时，你实际上正处于罗马式建筑的交汇界面上——这是诺曼国王们大力资助的建筑风格——在这里我们可以看到那些罗马式拱门，还有券廊等等。所以这里有狭窄的拱门，矮胖的拱门，矮胖的柱子。然后，在我们站立的、向那个空间开敞的地方，你又会看到哥特式建筑高耸的拱门。因此，伦敦塔内的这个地方和皇家小教堂（Chapel Royal）是哥特式风格最早期的表现形式。这是一个极其不可思议的空间。所以，这座教堂将在2023年迎来它的900岁生日。正如你所料，这里到处都是历史的痕迹、记忆和纪念碑。这座圣洗池可以追溯到1404年，你知道谁曾在这里接受洗礼吗？你没有任何理由知道，但霍加斯（Hogarth）曾在这里受洗。霍加斯曾在这一带生活过。我本来想猜一个15世纪的人，因为你抛出了1404年这个年份把我给难住了。所以霍加斯就是那些对科克巷幽灵持高度怀疑态度的人之一，他非常喜欢在这一带活动。是的，他在这里受洗，绝对是一个地地道道的当地人。如果我们沿着这里走下去，
and a Funeral, this is the scene of the final wedding. So it's where Hugh Grant jilts Duckface and goes off. Oh yeah. This is a perfect opportunity for you to revive your Hugh Grant is it raining oh that's so moving and so when you step inside yes suddenly you're back in the middle ages so here is so on the right as you go in you you've got a section of the cloisters, just to kind of really one of the four sides of the cloisters.
我们就会来到——在我看来——整个伦敦最充满历史鬼魂气息的单一空间。当我们沿着柱子旁边走，穿行在教堂内部，朝着主祭坛后面的区域走去时，我们的前方是一个小小的祭坛，上面供奉着圣母玛利亚的圣像。是的，是一个精美的圣像，总是抱着圣婴耶稣。现在，这个地方——紧邻圣母圣像的这个地方——是伦敦唯一已知曾显现过圣母玛利亚踪迹的地方。好吧，那你可得好好解释一下了。她大约在1180年左右显现过，也就是在修道院建立大约70年或60年之后。她出现了，并对一位名叫休伯特（Hubert）的教士说话，告诉他修道士们在进行礼拜仪式时出了差错。所以基本上她是在批评他们。是的，她用英语告诉休伯特他们该怎么做。我猜大概是用拉丁语，或者……阿拉姆语？谁知道她当时在说什么呢？我想我是不是问了太多问题？我猜是用诺曼法语，或者……阿拉姆语？谁知道她当时在说什么呢？我想我是不是问了太多问题？我猜是用拉丁语。因此，她告诉了休伯特他应该怎么做，而休伯特也顺从地照办了，随后圣母玛利亚便消失了。
But going in here, suddenly you are in this remarkable space and it's the meeting point. And so you come in and you basically you're at the interface of the Romanesque, which is the style of architecture that the norman kings were sponsoring so there we've got those romanesque arches and yeah so arcades and so on yeah so it's kind of narrow narrow arches yeah um squat arches squat pillars and then the place where we're standing kind of opening up onto that space you have the gothic yes soaring arches so so this and um the chapel in the in the tower of london is the earliest manifestations of the gothic and it's a kind of incredible incredible space and so so this you know this is a church that is going to be 900 years old in 2023 yeah um and so as you would expect it is just full of trace elements memories memorials to that history so this this
为了纪念这一事件，他们建造了这座美妙的小教堂，它直接依附在主祭坛的正后方。圣母礼拜堂（Lady Chapel）的主祭坛后方同样悬挂着一幅巨大的圣母画像。但在宗教改革之后，这个地方、所有这些空间都被变卖了，因为宗教改革派显然不会喜欢这些。所以教堂作为教区教堂被保留了下来，但这一部分——为纪念圣母玛利亚显现而建的圣母礼拜堂——
um font here dates from 1404 and do you know who was baptized there there's no reason why you would um uh hogarth hogarth who lived in the area i was going to guess someone from the 15th century because you're throwing me with 1404 so so hogarth was one of the guys who was very skeptical about um the cock lane ghost so he's very much a guy who was hanging around in this area yes he's baptized here being baptized very much very much a local um and if we walk down here um we come to uh what i think is in a way the most history haunted single the most single history haunted space in the whole of london because you see we we're going down the side of the uh around the pillars so we head towards the head of the church
被卖掉了。于是它被买下、被利用，被改造成了私人住宅，甚至变成了作坊。在18世纪20年代，这里曾是一家印刷厂。而在1724年，这家印刷厂招收了一名新学徒。我能猜到是谁吗？你猜猜看。是本杰明·富兰克林（Benjamin Franklin）吗？
behind the altar and ahead of us is a tiny altar which shows the virgin yeah um nice icon always with the baby jesus now this court this this place here next to the the icon of the virgin is the only known place to have hosted an appearance by the virgin mary in london well so you're gonna have to justify that so she appeared around 1180 so after the family you know some some kind of what's it's kind of 70 years 60 years after the founding of the priory and she turned up and she spoke to a canon called hubert and told him that the monks were doing the liturgy incorrectly so basically she was kind of telling them off yes she told hubert what they had to do in english i imagine it was in latin or yeah aramaic i mean
正是如此，多米尼克。确实是他。我知道的可比你想象的要多，汤姆。所以这个空间是唯一一个既出现过圣母玛利亚、又出现过本杰明·富兰克林的地方。我觉得还有其他人。我没记错的话，某个时期这里也曾有一位舞蹈大师在这里活动过吗？他们当时开办了舞蹈学校之类的地方吗？这里曾有一所舞蹈学校，也曾有过印刷厂，各种各样的机构都曾存在过。
who knows what she was talking i imagine i'm asking too many questions i imagine it was a norman french i meant or yeah aramaic i mean who knows what she was talking i imagine i'm asking too many questions i imagine in latin um and so she told hubert what he had to do and he obediently did it and then the virgin mary vanished right and so in honor of that they built um this wonderful chapel which is attached it's behind directly behind the altar built onto it the lady chapel again has a kind of huge great picture of the virgin behind the altar up here but this after the reformation this all this space all got sold off yeah because of course though the reformers would not have been keen yes so the church got so this got kept as a church to serve as a parish church but this bit the, the Lady Chapel, which was built in honour of the appearance of the Virgin Mary,
特维德罗普先生（Mr. Turvey Drop），对吧？来自《荒凉山庄》（Bleak House）。没错，正是。但我喜欢这里的原因在于，正如你所知，多米尼克，我一直是基督教历史如何塑造人类思想走向的坚定狂热崇拜者。你真是让我大开眼界。
that got sold off. And so it got bought up, it got used, it got turned into private accommodation, it got turned into workshops. And in the 1720s, this was a printer's. And in 1724, the printers took on a new assistant. Can I guess who it was? Have a guess. Was it Benjamin Franklin?
你真是让我大开眼界。基督教历史如何塑造人类思想走向的狂热崇拜者，以及对信仰时代、中世纪与启蒙时代之间延续性的感知——当然，许多人将启蒙时代视为一种激进的断裂，而我则认为它很大程度上是连续体的一部分。所以我觉得，就充满历史鬼魂的空间而言，这里绝对是……过去舞者的幽灵。过去舞者的幽灵。后来在19世纪，这座建筑又被教堂买回去了。所以现在遗址上的这个礼拜堂，其实是一种……
It was, Dominic. It was. I know more than you think, Tom. So this space is the only place that has featured both the Virgin Mary and Benjamin Franklin. And I think others. Am I not right in thinking that a dancing master was also involved with this space at some point? Did they have a dancing school or something? So there was a dancing school here, there was a printer, all kinds of things.
不，这是原汁原味的。你知道的，这个空间曾被改成作坊，后来里面的东西被清理出去，并重新被祝圣、归还给教堂。当时屋顶几乎要坍塌了，于是他们发起了一场募捐活动，最终在今年早些时候重新开放。当然，这里也是举行过许多著名婚礼的教堂，汤姆，不是吗？嗯，我提到了休·格兰特……你确实提过。德博拉·米特福德（Deborah Mitford）也曾在这里结婚，所以……所有这些都非常非常激动人心。
Mr. Turvey Drop, isn't it? Yeah, that's right. From Bleak House. That's right. Yeah. But the reason I love that is that, as you know, Dominic, I'm a great enthusiast for the way that Christian history has shaped the cast of thought. You astound me.
这里还有另外两个有趣的亮点，值得一提。你给我们带来了什么，汤姆？看上面，那里有一扇凸肚窗（oriel window），那是修道院院长在宗教改革前建造的，这样他就可以向下俯瞰，检查修士们是否行为端正。哦，是的，那是个非常不错的视角。所以这挺有意思的。但这里是修道院创始人拉希尔的陵墓。
You astound me. enthusiast for the way that christian history has shaped the cast of thought and the sense of continuity between you know the age of faith and the middle ages and the the age of the enlightenment yes of course which many people see as being rad you know radical discontinuity i would see as being very much part of a continuum and so i think that this, you know, in terms of spaces that are haunted by the past, this is... Ghosts of dancers past. Of dancers past. So it got brought back by the church in the 19th century. So this is the chapel on the site now is a sort of...
也就是最初建立修道院和医院的那位罗马人……正如我们所讨论的，伦敦这个地区充满了幽灵的传说，据说他的幽灵真的在这座教堂里游荡。因为故事是这样的：在19世纪，工人们打开了陵墓，其中一个人偷走了他的凉鞋，于是这个幽灵的传说便流传开来……非常奇怪，非常奇怪。不，因为他既不是圣人，也不是别的什么大人物，你为什么会想要一个死人的凉鞋？我猜这纯粹是为了编造故事吧。因为我记得我曾把这个讲给罗吉尔·克拉克听，他转过身对我说：“是的，这个故事已经在大概500个版本里出现过了。”所以再次说明，我不觉得这是真的。但它非常……不过汤姆，这难道不是有时在这个播客中会出现的那种情况吗？你讲了一个故事，结果发现完全是虚构的？好吧，这就要由听众来决定它是真是假了。
No, this is the authentic. You know, this was... This space was turned into workshops. They then got cleared out and it got reconsecrated um given back to the church and the roof was was about to collapse and they had an appeal so they it opened earlier this year and this of course has been um uh a church of notable weddings tom has it not well i mentioned um hugh grant you did uh deborah mitford got married here so um all very very very exciting.
好吧。我不会去断言拉希尔修道院长的幽灵是否会在他忌日那天实体化、并要求归还他的凉鞋。在进入广告休息时间之前，我想这座教堂已经在许多电影中出现过了，对吧？
And there are two kind of interesting other highlights, just to point out. What have you got for us, Tom? So up there, there's an oriole window, which is where the prior, just before the Reformation, built it so that he could gaze down and check that the monks were behaving themselves. Oh, yeah, that's a very nice view. So that's kind of nice. But here is the tomb of prior here who founded
我们要不要去看看有没有一份清单？嗯，我想可能确实有一份清单。我敢打赌，这座教堂一定出现在《罗宾汉：盗贼王子》（Robin Hood, Prince of Thieves）里。如果你猜对了，那可就太惊人了。你是《罗宾汉：盗贼王子》的粉丝吗，汤姆？是的，我很喜欢。是吗？凯文·科斯特纳（Kevin Costner）没有让你觉得烦人吗？我喜欢它那
the guy monastery in the hospital the original roman yes and um he is so we talked about how this is an area of london that is haunted by ghosts he reputedly literally haunts this church um because the story goes that um in the 19th century the tomb was opened by workmen who and one of them stole his sandal and so the ghost of the strange very strange very strange no because he's not um he's not he's not a saint or anything why would you want his sandal dead man's sandal i i think simply to set up the story because i remember saying i remember telling this to roger clark and he turned around and said yes that story has appeared in about 500 iterations so again i don't think so but it's very but i mean it's it's it's
独特的地理设定，从多佛（Dover）到无论哪里——伦敦，居然要经过哈里森长城（Hadrian's Wall）。关于罗宾汉的电影记录有些坎坷，不是吗？因为我总会想起罗素·克劳（Russell Crowe）扮演罗宾时的口音。《情尽威尼斯》（The End of the Affair），《莎翁情史》（Shakespeare in Love），《情尽威尼斯》出现了两次，《白雪公主与猎人》（Snow White and the Huntsman），还有《布偶大电影之最高通缉》（Muppets Most Wanted）。《布偶大电影之最高通缉》
lovely tom but is that one of those things that sometimes happens in this podcast where you tell a story that turns out to be totally untrue well it's up to the listener to decide whether it's true or not okay Okay. I'm not going to say whether Priory Hears Ghost materialises on the day of his death, demanding the return of his handle or not. Just before we go into the break, I think this church is featured in lots of films, hasn't it?
好吧，我们非常喜欢布偶……《复仇者联盟2：奥创纪元》（Avengers: Age of Ultron），《变形金刚5：最后的骑士》（Transformers: The Last Knight）。我们俩都是布偶的超级粉丝，是的，我们真的超爱布偶。所以有一期以布偶为主题的节目总是很棒的，我很很高兴看到我们打卡了这个心愿。带着这个心情，我想我们要进入一个广告休息时间，广告过后，我们将带着更多伦敦的秘密回归。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde）。我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。
Shall we go and see if there's a list? Well, I think there may be a list. And I'm prepared to bet that this church appeared in Robin Hood, Prince of Thieves. Well, it would be astonishing if you were right. Are you a fan of Robin Hood, Prince of Thieves. Well, it would be astonishing if you were right. You a fan of Robin Hood, Prince of Thieves, Tom? Yeah, I loved it. Did you? Yeah. Kevin Costner didn't annoy you? I loved its
这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝八卦爆料，在我们的问答环节中，我们将为你拉开娱乐产业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目，以及优先购买现场门票的权益，
distinctive geography, going from Dover to wherever it was, London, via Hadrian's Wall. Robin Hood films have a slightly checkered record, don't they? Because I always think of Russell Crowe's accent when he played Robin. So the end of the affair. Shakespeare in love um end of the affair twice it appears the golden age um snow white and the huntsman and the muppets most wanted muppets most wanted
请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。好了，欢迎回到《历史的余烬》。我们刚刚离开教堂，显然，我们在插播广告时留在教堂里是不合规矩的，所以出于礼貌我们离开了。现在汤姆把我们带到了某个人的牌匾前，我知道这个人对汤姆来说非常重要，是汤姆真正的英雄。“纪念威廉·华莱士爵士永垂不朽。”——那个苏格兰口音模仿得真不错，基本上就是梅尔·吉布森（Mel Gibson）版的苏格兰口音——他曾被施以绞刑、剖腹并车裂，而原因就是
well we're big fans avengers age of ultron transformers the last night we're big fans of the muppets on this uh yeah we are we love the muppets um so it's always good to have a muppets themed episode and i'm glad to see we've ticked that boxets on this. Yeah, we are. We love the Muppets. So it's always good to have a Muppets-themed episode, and I'm glad to see we've ticked that box. And on that note, I think we'll go to a break, and we shall come back after the ads with some more Secrets of London. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman, and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
嗯，我们非常喜欢《复仇者联盟2：奥创纪元》、《变形金刚5：最后的骑士》，我们节目组也非常喜欢布偶大电影，是的，我们确实很喜欢布偶。所以有一集以布偶为主题的节目总是很好的，我很高兴看到我们完成了这个心愿。顺便说一句，我想我们要去休息一下，广告过后我们将带着更多《伦敦的秘密》回来。我是玛丽娜·海德。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes, and early access to live tickets,
我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们共同主持《娱乐滑铁卢》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一点八卦的好去处，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想收听无广告节目、额外单集以及提前购买现场门票的权限，
head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. So, welcome back to The Rest Is History um we have just left the church obviously it wouldn't have done for us to stay in the church while advertising was taking place so we we left for the for reasons of decorum and now tom has brought us outside to the site of a plaque to somebody who i know is very close to tom's heart a real hero of tom's it's to the immortal memory of sir william wallace that was a very good scottish accent that was basically mel gibson scottish accent got hung drawn and quartered and the reason for that
请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史滑铁卢》，嗯，我们刚刚离开教堂，显然我们不可能在播放广告的时候留在教堂里，所以为了体面我们离开了，现在汤姆把我们带到了一个牌匾前，我知道这个人对汤姆来说非常重要，是汤姆真正的英雄，这是为了纪念不朽的威廉·华莱士爵士，那是一个非常好的苏格兰口音，基本上就是梅尔·吉布森的苏格兰口音，被施以绞刑、剖腹和车裂酷刑，原因就是
is that we are you know we're at smithfield and as we said in the first half this is one of the great open spaces um abutting the medieval uh walls the medieval limits of the city so um smithfield meant smooth field yeah place where you know all the cattle and everyone was bought we've got the meat market over there but because it was an open space um it could play host to all kinds of gatherings and there was obviously no more popular excuse for a gathering than to watch a rebel against uh his uh anointed liege lord be tortured to death but which is which is what happened here with william wallace you didn't write this caption that's for sure scottish patriot born at eldersley renfrewshire circa 1270 ad who from the year 1296 fought dauntlessly
就是你知道的，我们在史密斯菲尔德（Smithfield），正如我们在前半部分所说，这是连接中世纪城墙、中世纪城市边界的伟大开阔地之一，所以“史密斯菲尔德”的意思就是平坦的力场，对吧，一个你知道所有牛只和人们被买卖的地方，我们那边有肉类市场，但因为它是一个开阔地，它可以举办各种各样的集会，显然，没有什么比观看一个反叛国王的叛军被折磨致死更受欢迎的集会借口了，而这正是威廉·华莱士在这里发生的事情，你可没写这段说明文字，那是肯定的，苏格兰爱国者，生于伦弗鲁郡埃尔德斯利，约公元1270年，从1296年起勇敢地
in defence of his country's liberty and independence in the face of fearful odds and great hardship, eventually being betrayed and brought to London, blah, blah, blah, put to death. His example, heroism and devotion inspired those who came after him to win victory from defeat. And his memory remains for all time
为了保卫祖国的自由和独立，面对可怕的险境和巨大的艰难险阻，最终遭到背叛并被带到伦敦，啦啦啦，处以死刑。他的榜样、英雄主义和奉献精神激励了后来者从失败中赢得胜利。他的记忆将永远
a source of pride, honour and inspiration to his countryman that was mel gibson again yeah um yeah yeah so so tom you would not approve of that i would completely approve of it because the great cult of william wallace the the idea of him as a great patriotic defender of scottish independence was a product of um of of the union uh it was Scots who were confident in their British identity but who nevertheless were you know interested to to conserve the flame of a great Scottish a great Scottish hero now if you look closely there's a smaller plaque this memorial was placed here by Scots and friends at home and abroad by kind position of the governors of St Bartholomew's Hospital, 1956. So not an age of kind of rampant Scottish nationalism.
成为他的同胞们的骄傲、荣誉和灵感的源泉，那又是梅尔·吉布森，对，嗯，对，对，所以汤姆，你不会赞同那个吧，我完全赞同，因为伟大的威廉·华莱士崇拜，把他视为苏格兰独立伟大爱国卫士的想法，是工会的产物，那是对自己的英国身份充满自信，但尽管如此，依然有兴趣保护一个伟大的苏格兰英雄火焰的苏格兰人，现在如果你仔细看，有一个较小的牌匾，这个纪念碑是由国内外的苏格兰人和朋友在圣巴塞olomew医院理事会的友好准许下于1956年设立的，所以并不是一个盛行狂热苏格兰民族主义的时代。
No, but just before the revival, I suppose, of Scottish nationalism. And there are still some very desultory. There's a few flowers here, a little card there. That's from Rod Stewart. There's a thistle. Or Alex Salmond, I think. There's some tattered Scottish flags. Yeah, yeah. there that's from roger stewart uh there's a thistle or alex salmon scottish flags um yeah yeah um but i mean so essentially traitors to the king would you know this was one of the places
不，只是在苏格兰民族主义复兴之前，我想。这里仍然有一些非常零星的花。这有一小张卡片，那是罗德·斯图尔特送的。这有一朵蓟花，或者亚历山大·萨蒙德，我想。有一些破烂的苏格兰国旗。对，对。那个是罗杰·斯图尔特送的，嗯，有一朵蓟花或者亚历山大·萨蒙德，苏格兰国旗，嗯，对，嗯，但是我的意思是，本质上对国王的叛徒会，你知道，这就是其中一个地方
where you would come to watch a good um a good hanging and drawing and and quartering um and uh it so the guts would then join all the guts from the butchers. And they would then be swept into the river fleet, which is over there, which we may come to in due course. So the stench of this was kind of overpowering in the Middle Ages. And actually, among the ghosts that haunt this place are literary ghosts, ghosts from fiction. And one of them is pip in great expectations by uh by charles dickens um who when he comes to london goes to the offices of mr
你会来这里观看一场精彩的、精彩的绞刑、剖腹和车裂，然后这些内脏就会和屠夫们的内脏混在一起。然后它们会被扫进弗利特河，就在那边，我们等会儿可能会去到那里。所以中世纪这里的恶臭简直令人窒息。事实上，在这个地方游荡的幽灵中，还有文学幽灵，来自小说的幽灵。其中一个是查尔斯·狄更斯笔下《远大前程》里的皮普，他来到伦敦后去了mr
jaggers the uh the lawyer who has been entrusted with his you know the legal details of his his inheritance his great expectations and it's just down there just the side corner so between the the hospital and the church there's a side alley called little britain and that's just down there just the side corner so between the the hospital and the church there's a side alley called little britain and that's where he had his offices and dickens says that pip comes here from the country and he walks up towards jaggers's office and the stench from the uh from the meat market kind of makes him almost faint well the market is still here i mean we're within the market but there isn't a kind of there's no stench. But, so disemboweling has happened here, but other things happened as well.
贾格尔斯的办公室，这位律师被委托处理他的遗产的法律细节，他的远大前程，它就在那下面，就在那个转角，所以在医院和教堂之间有一条叫小不列颠的侧巷，它就在那下面，就在那个转角，所以在医院和教堂之间有一条叫小不列颠的侧巷，他的办公室就在那里，狄更斯说皮普从乡下来到这里，他向贾格尔斯的办公室走去，肉类市场传来的恶臭几乎让他昏厥，好吧，市场还在，我的意思是我们在市场里面，但这里没有那种恶臭。不过，这里确实发生过剖腹取肠的事，但也发生过其他事情。
And among the things that happened here, people would congregate for great kind of festive occasions, great social occasions, of which the preeminent one was St. Bartholomew's Fair. Yes, of course, very famous. Very, very famous. Established by the priory in 1123 um site of uh you'd have tournaments here as well so um there was a famous tournament under um rich the second
在发生的事情中，人们会聚集在一起参加各种盛大的节日、盛大的社交活动，其中最显赫的就是圣巴塞洛缪集会。是的，当然，非常有名。非常，非常有名。由修道院于1123年建立，这里也是举办比武大会的场所以及理查二世统治时期举办的一场著名比武大会
that chaucer played a key role in organizing but you would also have meetings that weren't necessarily sanctioned by the crown yeah and the most famous of those is when the peasants, who were embroiled in the Peasants' Revolt, marching on London, they all congregated here. They did indeed, didn't they? This is the, isn't this the showdown? This is the showdown, and led by Wat Tyler. Yeah.
乔叟在其中发挥了关键的组织作用，但你也会有不一定得到王室批准的聚会，对，其中最著名的是农民起义中的农民，他们卷入其中，向伦敦进军，都聚集在这里。他们的确这么做了，不是吗？这就是，这难道不是决战吗？这就是决战，由沃特·泰勒领导。对。
And Wat Tyler gets struck down here by the Lord Mayor of London. He does, yes, because he doesn't show enough deference to Richard II. And so it's... So there's a very new plaque here. Well, so it's a plaque raised to the memory of the peasants who took place, who took part in the revolt. Some people might consider classic sort of radical tradition it's been placed slightly too high so you can't really read what's at the top
沃特·泰勒在这里被伦敦市长击倒。他的确被击倒了，是的，因为他对理查二世不够恭敬。所以这是……这里有一块崭新的牌匾。好吧，这是一块为了纪念参加起义的农民而设立的牌匾。有些人可能会认为这是一种经典的激进传统，它被挂得稍微有点高，所以你根本看不清顶部写的是什么
so the memory is already is already fading the william wallace one is much clearer yeah but there's something here uh what's it say it's something about and the plight of the people this is a terrible metaphor for the uh the plight of the british left i think that um but it's very hard to see what's so there's a mention of what tyler being killed here and of uh john ball who preached the uh you know when adam he when adam delved who then was the gentleman um so this was unveiled by um ken loach among other people um and there's a quote here from Thomas Paine on a plaque. If the barons merited a monument to be erected at Runnymede, that's a reference to Magna Carta,
所以这段记忆已经在逐渐消退，威廉·华莱士的那块要清晰得多，但这里有什么，它写的是什么，是关于人民的困境，我认为这是对英国左翼困境的一个可怕的比喻，但是很难看清上面写的是什么，所以提到了沃特·泰勒在这里被杀，以及约翰·鲍尔，他宣扬了，你知道的，当亚当在挖掘时，谁又是绅士呢，所以这是由肯·洛奇等人揭幕的，牌匾上引用了托马斯·佩恩的一句话：如果说男爵们配得上在兰尼米德竖立一座纪念碑，那是对《大宪章》的引用，
Tyler merited one in Smithfield. Thomas Paine, 1791. Of course, the great thing about this is it's all a kind of invent... Like Magna Carta, it's kind of an invention, isn't it? The President's Revolt isn't a kind of proto-socialist uprising, really. But it's become part of that kind of invented radical tradition i suppose yeah and and that again absolutely is part of the fascination of london's history it's that the memories of what happened here don't have to be accurate for them themselves in turn to become part of history i think jeremy corbyn has been here tom i always like to do a little
泰勒就配得上在史密斯菲尔德拥有一座。托马斯·佩恩，1791年。当然，这最棒的地方在于，这一切都是一种发明……就像《大宪章》一样，这是一种发明，对吧？农民起义并不是一种类似社会主义的起义，真的。但它已经成为那种被发明的激进传统的一部分，我想是的，而这绝对是伦敦历史魅力的一部分，那就是在这里发生的事情的记忆，并不需要准确，就能它们自己反过来成为历史的一部分，我想杰里米·科尔宾来过这里，汤姆，我总是喜欢做一个小小的
well well you know there's there's something for all tastes here so there's something for scottish nationalists there's something for members of momentum and there's something for radical protestants because um here there is a third memorial yeah uh which was erected 1870 by the protestant alliance that's a evangelical group i i guess so uh and that commemorates the um so we've had disembowelings uh but most notoriously on the reign of queen mary yes there were the burning of heretics um so the burnings that took place here are essentially what gave mary the first her nickname of bloody mary um and the great theme of Fox's Book of Martyrs, this sense that the revival of Catholicism
好吧，你知道的，这里能满足所有人的口味，所以这里有给苏格兰民族主义者的，有给动量运动成员的，也有给激进新教徒的，因为这里有第三座纪念碑，是由新教同盟于1870年竖立的，那是一个福音派组织，我想是的，为了纪念，所以我们经历过剖腹，但在玛丽女王统治时期最臭名昭著的是，是的，有焚烧异端，所以这里发生的焚烧事件基本上是给玛丽一世赢得了“血腥玛丽”的绰号，而福克斯的《殉道者之书》的主题，这种复兴天主教的意识
would mean Protestants being burnt in Smithfield, haunted the imaginings of Protestants throughout the late 16th, 17th century. Within a few feet of this spot, says the memorial, John Rogers, John Bradford, John Philpott, and other servants of god suffered death by fire for the faith of christ in the years 1555 1556 1557 now of course since we're revisionist about the peasants revolt we should also be a little bit revisionist about
将意味着新教徒在史密斯菲尔德被烧死，这在16世纪末、17世纪整整困扰着新教徒的想象。纪念碑上写道，就在这个地方的几英尺范围内，约翰·罗杰斯、约翰·布拉德福德、约翰·菲尔波特和其他上帝的仆人，在1555年、1556年、1557年为了基督的信仰在火中丧生，现在当然，既然我们对农民起义持修正主义态度，我们也应该对
uh bloody mary who gets a bit of a bad press doesn't she because um you know burning heretics was hardly unusual behavior in the 16th century and some people would argue she was just unlucky in her posthumous reputation. Yeah, had she lived a bit longer, I'm sure... And had Catholicism become enshrined, once again, no one would say it was... History would remember it very differently. Just where we're standing in 1849 um some workmen were digging a sewer as they were digging it they found a mass of blackened stones and these it was claimed were
血腥玛丽持一点修正主义态度，因为她受到的恶评有点多，不是吗？因为，你知道，在16世纪，焚烧异端算不上什么寻常行为，有些人会争辩说，她只是在身后的名誉上运气不好。是的，如果她多活一会儿，我确信……如果天主教再次成为国教，没有人会说那是……历史会对它有截然不同的记忆。就在我们站立的1849年，一些工人在挖下水道时，在挖掘过程中他们发现了一大堆发黑的石头，据称这些石头是
covered with ashes and human bones charred and partially consumed and an antiquary came to inspect it and had absolutely no doubt that he was gazing at the remnants of the incinerated Protestant martyrs. What, all those years later? Again, Dominic. I'm much too sceptical. You and your scepticism towards these wonderful stories. There's one on the subject of horrendous occasions from the past that commemorate in open spaces. There's one other. We won't go and look at it now because we haven't really got time.
覆盖着灰烬和烧焦且部分损毁的人骨，一位古物学家前来视察，他毫不怀疑自己正在凝视焚烧清新教殉道者的残骸。什么，那么多年以后？得了吧，多米尼克。我太怀疑了。你和你的怀疑主义针对这些美妙的故事。关于过去在开阔地上纪念的恐怖场合，还有一个。还有另一个。我们现在不去看了，因为我们实在没时间了。
But around the corner on the other side of of uh the meat market there's an open space uh charterhouse green which was originally a plague pit and during the black death so they were developing the tube line and they discovered all the the bones came tumbling out um and charterhouse green subsequently there was a priory was founded there carthusians um and again in the reformation all got sold off became a famous school that then moved out one of the more famous private schools isn't it so charterhouse i don't know where it went but is it sorry sorry godalming godalming okay um having an encyclopedic knowledge of schools well very very impressive. Someone has to.
但在肉类市场的另一边的转角处，有一个开阔地，查特豪斯绿地，这里最初是一个瘟疫坑，在黑死病期间，当时他们正在修建地铁线路，他们发现所有的骨头都滚了出来，查特豪斯绿地后来建起了一座修道院，属于加尔都西会，同样在宗教改革时期被全部卖掉，变成了一所著名的学校，后来搬走了，是比较著名的私立学校之一，对吧，所以查特豪斯，我不知道它搬到哪去了，但是，是戈多尔明吗，戈多尔明，好的，拥有百科全书般的学校知识，非常非常深刻。总得有人知道。
So, essentially, I mean, the sense of history here is kind of almost oppressive. And unless you knew to look, to go through that gate yard, to go into St. Bartholomew the Great, to know what happened in St. Bartholomew's Hospital, and certainly to know what happened in this open space. What Tyler, William Wallace, Protestant martyrs. It's the coordination of the banality of the modern day landscape. St Bartholomew's Hospital and certainly to know what happened in this open space what Tyler William Wallace it's the coordination of the modern day landscape with the layering of frankly a very bloody and violent history isn't it yeah that you know people are bustling well they're not even bustling about actually a few people are sort of trudging in a slightly disconsolate way
所以，基本上，我的意思是，这里的历史感几乎令人窒息。除非你知道去寻找，去穿过那个门院，去走进大圣巴塞洛缪教堂，知道圣巴塞洛缪医院发生了什么，当然还要知道这个开阔地上发生了什么。沃特·泰勒、威廉·华莱士、新教殉道者。这是现代景观的平庸与坦白说极其血腥暴力的历史层叠的结合，不是吗？是的，你知道人们在熙熙攘攘，好吧，其实他们甚至没有在熙熙攘攘，少数人正以一种稍微沮丧的方式
past at the end of the day from their office on their way to the commute home and and the memories are preserved in the the street now yeah there's one last place i'd like to okay but do you think i mean probably there's never been a point in the history of this part of london where it has been quieter and more desultory than it is now. Do you think? I think that's true. For so much of its history, this was a bustling, you know, it would have been, maybe the analogy is if you were to visit a city like, I don't know, Delhi or Istanbul or something, crowded, you know, rich and poor jumbled up together, hawkers in the streets, pickpockets. Yeah, and with the prospect of a good execution
在一天结束时从他们的办公室走过，在通勤回家的路上，而这些记忆现在被保存在街道中，对吧，还有一个地方我想去，好吧，但是你觉得，伦敦这一地区历史上大概从来没有像现在这样安静和零星过吧。你觉得呢？我认为是这样的。在其历史的大部分时间里，这里一直是一个熙熙攘攘的，你知道的，也许可以类比成如果你去参观一个像，我不知道，德里或伊斯坦布尔之类的城市，拥挤不堪，富人和穷人混杂在一起，街头小贩，扒手。是的，还有一场精彩处决的前景
so yeah i mean there's no prospect of that now no so so in many ways london has gone downhill i think it's less interesting um but that's precisely what history podcasts are for to bring back the spirit of to bring to conjure up yeah to conjure up the vanished ghosts yeah um and actually what gives you a very good sense of just how horrible uh this this place would have been is that we so we're now walking parallel to the great victorian structure of the uh of the meat market um away from the open space where the burnings and the disembowelings happened. And we're going downhill. And the reason that we're going downhill is that we're plunging into a river valley.
所以，是的，我的意思是现在没有那种前景了，没有，所以在很多方面，伦敦走下坡路了，我认为它没那么有趣了，但那正是历史播客的意义所在，带回那种精神，唤起，是的，唤起那些消逝的幽灵，是的，实际上，能让你真切感受到这个地方曾经有多么可怕的原因是，我们现在正沿着肉类市场的伟大维多利亚式建筑平行行走，远离发生焚烧和剖腹的开阔地。我们正在下坡。我们下坡的原因是我们正在陷入一个河谷。
And the river that we're heading towards is the River Fleet. So that is now, for those people who don't know, the Fleet is probably the most famous, isn't it, of London's vanished rivers. So the fleet gives its name to fleet street which is obviously probably not anymore but for certainly when we were growing up was synonymous with newspapers um and when did the fleet vanish tom well it's it so it starts to get covered over um 17th 18th as late as the 19th century you could still sail up um a section of the fleet but the value of the fleet and one of the other reasons why the meat market is here is that you could sweep the carcasses you know so all the guts that you've hacked out when you're when you're you're doing your joints you could
我们要去的河是弗利特河。所以对于那些不知道的人来说，现在弗利特河可能是伦敦最著名的消失的河流了，不是吗？所以弗利特河给舰队街（Fleet Street）提供了名字，显然现在可能不是了，但当我们长大时，它绝对是报纸的同义词，那么弗利特河是什么时候消失的呢，汤姆，嗯，它是，它开始被覆盖起来，17世纪、18世纪，直到19世纪，你仍然可以乘船逆流而上穿过弗利特河的一段，但弗利特河的价值以及肉类市场建在这里的另一个原因，是你可以把尸体扫进去，你知道的，所以当你切割肉块时所有砍下来的内脏，你可以
just sweep it into the into the river some listeners may remember we had a podcast about disease with kyle harper and he was talking about you know cholera and dysentery and all these things and he would not be impressed no by the uh by the standards of hygiene no well and this um there are three very famous lines by jonathan swift who wrote about the fleet sweepings from butcher's stalls dungung, guts and blood. Drowned puppies, stinking sprats, all drenched in mud. Dead cats and turnip tops come tumbling down the flood. Well, anyway, this podcast is sponsored by the London Tourist Board. I mean, to be fair, there's no evidence of that right now.
直接把它扫进河里，有些听众可能还记得，我们曾和凯尔·霍珀做过一个关于疾病的播客，他谈到了霍乱、痢疾和所有这些事情，他对卫生标准是不会留下好印象的，没有，关于乔纳森·斯维夫特的诗有三句非常著名，他写过弗利特河：来自屠夫摊位的清扫物，粪便、内脏和血液。淹死的幼犬，发臭的小鲱鱼，全都浸在泥里。死猫和萝卜头顺着洪水滚滚而下。无论如何，这个播客是由伦敦旅游局赞助的。我的意思是，公平地说，现在没有任何迹象表明这一点。
So the fleet was, by this stage, until it got covered over, was quite broad. So Fleet Street, where it crosses the River Fleet just in front of St Paul's Cathedral, Lugget Hill, that was a ford. So that was the reason it's called Fleet Street is because you could cross the fleet there. But it all got covered over. And you remember we started this episode on hoban viaduct
所以在这个阶段，直到它被盖住之前，弗利特河相当宽。所以舰队街，在圣保罗大教堂前穿过弗利特河的地方，勒德盖特山，那是一个浅滩。所以它之所以叫舰队街，是因为你可以在那里过河。但它后来都被盖住了。你还记得我们在霍本高架桥开始这一集的
we did indeed and the viaduct is basically built over the river valley of the fleet and the fleet marks um one of the kind of that you know one one of the uh the the urban boundaries and it's on the other side of the fleet i just want to show you one last one last kind of place of horror ah tom um you lure me up to london with these but i think but i think you'll enjoy it because it's it's a fictional place of horror right very good and we've already mentioned i like any place of horror factual or fictional to be honest with you we've already mentioned the novelist who created this fictional place of horror all right excellent and it is of course charles dickens and the place that we're heading towards is the place where the young oliver twist when he comes to london gets picked up by the artful dodger please sir i want some more um
我们确实如此，高架桥基本上是建在弗利特河谷上的，弗利特河标志着……你知道的，城市边界之一，而在弗利特河的另一边，我只想带你去看最后一个恐怖的地方，啊，汤姆，你用这些把引诱到伦敦来，但我认为你会喜欢，因为这是一个虚构的恐怖地方，对，非常好，我们已经提到了，老实说，我喜欢任何恐怖地方，无论是真是假，我们已经提到了创造这个虚构恐怖地方的小说家，太好了，当然就是查尔斯·狄更斯，我们要去的地方是年轻的奥利弗·特维斯特来到伦敦后被机灵鬼带走的地方，先生，请给我多一点，
that people will be saying at the end of this podcast i certainly hope so and he gets taken and he gets taken by the artful dodger um toger to visit a pleasant old gentleman and his hopeful pupils. And of course, the pleasant old gentleman is Fagin, and the hopeful pupils are the Pickpockets. So we're coming down now to, well, it's now a major road, but the river fleet runs beneath it. And we cross there um and then we will come to um saffron hill you're you're never happier listeners to our christmas carol podcast will know that you're never happier than bringing us to the dingiest dreariest spot imaginable we're coming down some steps here and there's a stream of dog urine. Yeah. There's a DHL van.
人们在这个播客结束时会这么说，我当然希望如此，他被机灵鬼带走了，带去拜访一位慈祥的老绅士和他的希望之星学生们。当然，慈祥的老绅士就是费根，希望之星学生就是小偷。所以我们现在来到一条主要道路，但弗利特河就在它下面流过。我们在那里过马路，然后我们将来到萨弗伦山（Saffron Hill），听众朋友们看过我们的《圣诞颂歌》播客就会知道，你最高兴的就是带我们去你能想象到的最阴暗、最沉闷的地方，我们正顺着一些台阶往下走，这里有一股狗尿味。对。有一辆DHL货车。
Dripping down the steps. We're at the back of some sort of loading bay. It's the most unromantic corner of London you could possibly imagine. So this is Saffron Hill. Which definitely does not live up to its surname. So this was all owned by the Bishop of Ely. So you remember in our rich the third episode um we talked about how richard of gloucester before having but hastings beheaded
顺着台阶往下滴。我们在某种卸货区的后面。这是伦敦你能想象到的最不浪漫的角落。这就是萨弗伦山。这里绝对名不副实。所以这里以前都属于伊利主教。所以你还记得在我们的理查三世那一集中，我们谈到了格洛斯特的理查在下令将黑斯廷斯斩首之前
asked the bishop of ely for strawberries from his garden he did indeed yes so the bishop of ely's garden was kind of in this neighborhood um and it's uh saffron hill because saffron grew here now as you say there's no trace of saffron now yeah so we're kind of very it's it's very narrow there are very high buildings on either side blank buildings yeah i wouldn't bring people sightseeing here kind of gloomy and miserable but this is this is where fagin's lair was um and i know that you're a big dickens fan so um perhaps you have i have a little reading here perhaps you have a little reading that you'd like you didn't expect that um but well actually you did because you put it in the note so um so here we go oliver could not help bestowing a few hasty
向伊利主教索要他花园里的草莓，他的确这么做了，是的，所以伊利主教的花园就在这个附近，之所以叫萨弗伦山，是因为这里曾经长过藏红花。现在正如你所说，一点藏红花痕迹都没有了，所以我们身处非常狭窄的地方，两边都是非常高的建筑，光秃秃的建筑，是的，我不会带人来这里观光，有点阴暗悲惨，但这就是费根的巢穴所在，我知道你是狄更斯的超级粉丝，所以，也许你有一段小小的朗读，你可能有一段你想读的小朗读，你没想到吧，其实你料到了，因为你把它写在笔记里了，所以，我们开始吧，奥利弗在路过时，忍不住瞥了几眼
glances on the other side of the way as he passed along. A dirtier or more wretched place he had never seen. The street was very narrow and muddy and the air was impregnated with filthy odours. They've played quite a considerable part in this episode. There were a good many small shops but the only stock in trade appeared to be heaps of children who even at that time of night were crawling in and out of the doors or screaming from the inside. The sole places that seemed to prosper amid the general blight of the place were the public houses, and in them, Tom Holland, the lowest orders of Irish, who were generally the lowest orders of anything, were wrangling with might and main. I hope my wife isn't listening to this.
路过时匆匆瞥了另一边几眼。他从未见过比这更肮脏、更悲惨的地方。街道非常狭窄泥泞，空气中弥漫着污秽的气味。它们在这一集中扮演了相当重要的角色。有很多小商店，但唯一的商品似乎是一堆堆的孩子，他们甚至在那种时间的夜晚还在门里爬进爬出，或者在里面尖叫。在这个地方普遍的败落中，唯一似乎生意兴隆的是酒馆，而里面，汤姆·霍兰，最低阶层的爱尔兰人，通常是任何阶层中最低的，正在大声争吵。我希望我妻子没在听这个。
Covered ways and yards, which here and there diverged from the main street, disclosed little knots of houses where drunken men and women were positively wallowing in the filth and from several of the doorways great ill-looking fellows were cautiously emerging bound to all appearance upon no very well disposed or harmless errands yes so there we are and so you mentioned that the uh the taverns uh and one last link with oliver twist is ahead of us there's a pub that is now called the one ton but dickens knew as the three cripples three cripples and uh that that that's fagin and bill sykes is local so that's where they uh and there's some sort of lightly looking Bill Sykes figures lurking outside the park. Yes, they're dogs on
蜿蜒的小路和庭院从主街向四周分叉，隐约可以看到一小群房屋，醉酒的男女在污秽中打滚，几个门口小心翼翼地钻出一些相貌凶恶的家伙，显然不是去干什么正经或无害的差事。是的，所以就是这样，你提到了酒馆，与奥利弗·特维斯特的最后一个联系就在我们前方，有一家现在叫“一吨”的酒吧，但狄更斯认识它时叫“三个残废”，那是费根和比尔·赛克斯的地盘，所以他们……酒吧外面潜伏着一些看起来鬼鬼祟祟的比尔·赛克斯式人物。是的，有狗在
binder twine plotting break-ins So I agree, Dominic, that although there may not be a huge amount to see Well, there's nothing to see, Tom Well, there's a tavern but I mean, once you know
用捆扎绳策划入室盗窃，所以我同意，多米尼克，虽然这里可能没有太多可看的，好吧，这里什么也没有，汤姆，好吧，有一家酒馆，但我的意思是，一旦你知道
that this is Fagin's Lair... You have to know. And there's a message here I think you have for the listeners, Tom. They should venture out and dig up the layers of history beneath even the most unprepossessing neighbourhood. Well, the thing is that it's true of London, it's true of lots of places... Of Stevenage, of Slough...
这里是费根的巢穴……你必须得知道。我想你在这里给听众带了一个信息，汤姆。他们应该去冒险，挖掘隐藏在即使是最不起眼的街区底下的历史层层。好吧，事实是，伦敦是这样的，很多地方也是这样的……斯蒂夫尼奇，斯劳……
Maybe not of Slough, true of lots of places. Of Stevenage, of Slough. Maybe not of Slough, but of lots of places that, you know, obviously the more you know of what goes on, the more you have a sense of the past oozing up out of the tarmac, out of the brickwork. Like the bowels of some dismembered Scot. Indeed. Flung into the fleet. Wash away with the dead dogs.
也许斯劳不是，但很多地方是这样的。斯蒂夫尼奇，斯劳。也许斯劳不是，但很多地方是这样的，你知道的，显然你对发生的事情了解越多，你就会越有一种历史从柏油路面、从砖墙中渗出来的感觉。就像某个被分尸的苏格兰人的内脏。确实。扔进弗利特河。和死狗一起被冲走。
I think it's just about beginning to rain. So on that note, I think we should say farewell to our listeners. Yes. And we will see you next time. A farewell from London town. Fancy a quick pint? Yeah, let's go. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening,
我想雨快要开始下了。因此，我觉得我们应该向听众们道别了。是的。我们下次再见。来自伦敦城的告别。想喝杯快酒吗？走吧，去吧。感谢收听《历史其余部分》。要想收听独家节目、提前点播、无广告收听，
and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A,
并加入我们的聊天社区，请在 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐其余部分》。这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、评论、一点八卦的地方，在我们的问答环节中，
we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们揭开娱乐的面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚启动了会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、独家节目和提前获取现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。